jenna what what happens if we've already
done it wrong yeah
what happens if we went rogue and did
like blue and
tips and turquoise because i messed up
you lost me at two needles
what's a bee
hi everyone i'm janish meeting i'm
changu and mina kanju lakota enrolled
cheyenne river lakota sioux tribe and i
play regan wells on
rutherford falls here today we have
three of the writers we have marcos
louis venos we have ty leclaire we have
tazma chavez
i was also a writer on rutherford falls
and we have our
three co-executive producers sierra
teller ornelas ed helms
and mike shure as i understand it what
is happening now is you
janna are going to lead a beating
tutorial and while you do that i will be
asking questions
from this magic bowl of questions that
was provided to us
so that we can all talk about our
experience of making the show i have
been
uh beating since i was about seven or
eight years old
and i was taught by my grandmother
beadwork is a really
popular traditional art form that a lot
of natives
practice including myself it's also it
was and used as an incredible form of
storytelling
so like a long time ago and even today
native women would be dresses that had
traditional stories and so it was a way
for
mothers to educate their children it was
a way to like mark
histories um so it's really embedded not
only just as an art form but also
um just culturally in various nations
today we're gonna be a adorable little
peacock in honor of
peacock where you can find rutherford
falls this peacock we're going to use
the style
called two needle applique and
we have two needles attached to two
different threads i went ahead and
threaded the first needle for you so
this is going to be
um called our line
thread so this is where we're going to
like lay down
like put the beads on this needle
thread them onto this line thread and
then this needle that is
not attached yet to your pattern
is our tacking thread okay and our
tacking thread
what we're going to do is we're going to
slowly follow the lines of the pattern
of the feathers
with uh the green color that i sent to
you
like the outline of a green peacock
feather um
so i put my beads in the lid of
this kit you want something
shallow that you can dig the beads out
of these beads are
extremely small do you have any that are
more perhaps like basketball size that
would be easier to get onto
or do you have reading glasses for me
i will read the first question what was
the weirdest moment
in the writer's room and i think to
answer that question we
should go right to our showrunner and
fearless leader sierra taylor ornelas
that is so hard okay so the weirdest
moment in our writer's room would have
to
be covid like i don't know
it's a terrible answer but that's pretty
much
that was the weirdest moment that i
could remember it was not what wasn't
what what was the moment that it was
like oh we're shutting down
we were in the middle of our production
meeting for the for the pilot
we were literally for the first time oh
my crew
had gathered around around a big table
we were going through the pilot scripts
and uh sierra was um it was introducing
herself by naming her clans which is
uh which you should do right now let's
pause for a second
name your clan i don't like to do it
when when someone tells me to do it
because i'm a natural contrarian do it
so it's like i'm not gonna do it dad
i'm not just gonna save my clans all the
time but i will because i should because
my mom will be mad if i don't um yeah to
a sierra nelson shane
behind schleich brushes
nelly uh my name is sierra i am navajo
born of the edgewater clan i'm edgewater
born for the mexican people
so now imagine if you will we're all
gathered around this table and we're so
excited because we're
finally starting the the process of
shooting the first episode of this show
as sierra is saying her clans i get a
text that says uh where everything is
shutting down because of this global
pandemic that wasn't i mean besides
being scary
and and awful it was also i think you're
probably right the weirdest moment
uh ed what was your favorite line from
the show
my favorite line of the show
oh it's probably it's in the trailer
it's when bobby yang
uh played by the amazing jessie lee i
say something like
you can't change history deirdre and
then bobby says
unless you have a time machine and then
bobby goes and you don't because if you
did
you'd go back and tell yourself not to
buy that blazer
and it kills me every time i i've seen
the trailer now 300 times
and it makes me laugh every single time
and i can't wait to see it in the
episode again because it's going to make
me laugh again
all right jana favorite line from the
show there's a line uh a a
scene that i did with michael gray eyes
who plays terry thomas
and basically kind of complaining to him
and saying this is like nobody wants to
work with me because i'm a city indian
and i'm successful and and he says
you're not successful i love that too
that's so funny let's do a show-and-tell
and q
a real quick what do we got like i'm
obviously a beginner beater
but if i were a very proficient beater
such as yourself
this would take this peacock might take
17 years for
this amazing cartoon peacock
uh nathan and regan gift each other
edible arrangements in the show whose
idea was that and why
i think i feel like marco should answer
this
it was sort of my idea but also sierra's
idea we we've been friends for
over a decade now and we started uh
we when we were first starting our
friendship it was sort of like in any
relationship where you kind of like
hide the trash parts of yourself before
you like reveal them
and there was one time where sierra like
in deep confidence uh told me she was
like i secretly love edible
edible arrangements and i also was like
me too
and we talked about how like all we want
is someone to send us one
and so and now over time anytime uh
either one of us has a success we send
the other an edible arrangement
but we always do it from a fake
celebrity so i sent
one i think from barack obama one day
one from adam sandler down there to wish
me well on the show
it was a really wonderful moment
this is like this is a a question that's
designed to make you
do impressions of the characters okay so
uh ed do a one second
impression of the following characters
without using words
terry
that's really good that's a really good
terry wow he's an actor
well done all right jana do a one second
impression of uh of nathan
without using words
is that i feel like i feel like that was
like a like if the fonz was on crystal
meth
because my bangs are so flop they're
like very food or sprayed
all right let's get a beating update how
are we doing jana
yeah everybody show your work
oh my gosh you're so fast what does snag
mean
and how is it used in the show snag
means getting on with someone
at least that's what it is in my area
but there's also differences right
there's a regional difference
in the way snag is used so you're you're
from the northeast
snagging you're hooking up yeah but then
sierra you are from arizona and what do
you say
we say snagging out and vulgar it can
also be
a noun right yeah like he he or she is a
snag
oh that that's how it that that's that's
the origin then
that makes sense that means like like
that person is a catch kind of like
that's
like a catch that's who she's like
hooking up with yeah
or he's hooking up with they're old
snags they're saying they're old snags
uh and again i'm i'm just the messenger
so don't get upset at this
the question is who do you like the most
out of mike ed or sierra
wait who's answering the question anna
oh
yes jana oh god i'm sweating so much
there is there is a right answer we all
know what it is you can just say it
um i'm i'm gonna say ed oh no
wow you know lateral violence jana
sierra is my favorite
i feel like we're maybe sisters from
different misters
yeah sierra made it possible for me to
make it to the second
uh screen test of the show because
uh on the way there i crashed my car
spun out of control rammed my 2004 ford
escape into the side of the 134
totaled it immediately and really the
first thing that came to my mind was i
gotta make it to the screen test
so before i called the police i called
sierra to be like
help i gotta get to the screen to best
say back to my car
and she came and picked me up and we
like two little criminals abandoned my
broken car on the side of the highway
and
drove to universal yes we do
ed uh this is a little bit of a thinker
but what do you hope people come away
with after watching this show
joy i agree oh i really just hope that
people
get huge chuckles out of this show
and i think that there are some
opportunities to think and reflect a
little bit
and if that is if if that happens for
people
too then that's awesome um but
uh i really hope that this show puts
some positive energy
into the world i love that mm-hmm our
degree
everybody show jana your beauty work and
then janet will
go give everybody a letter grade
i like marcos is doing his own thing
it's nice sierra let's get
closer here oh
oh that looks great and you know it's
something
oh there you go there you go
it looks nice a little bit splotchy but
i if i had reading glasses on because
i'm
i'm 90 then i could actually
do this but i feel like i'm making like
like 20 or 30 punches through from the
back just to find the right spot
yeah that's normal marcos what is
what is the key to writing the perfect
joke for ed helms
i feel like the key to writing the
perfect joke is uh always
having like a one word uh
one word after the joke uh that he can
put his ed helm spin on like
when bobby gives that zinger in the
trailer and you go what
it's so funny every time it's so good
so i feel like giving like a one word
just ed helms reaction is
always the key to it i feel like ty
what's the key to writing the perfect
janish meeting joke
i want to say it's like giving
jenna a little space to sit with the
line
after i feel like there's always like a
little bit like of a
a a regan uh response
either it's with the eyes like i
remember the trailer michael graham says
like
it's not worth you know being friends
with white people you do this
like cast
here's one uh tosma i guess go ahead and
answer this one can viewers expect to
see
beadwork and other native art like what
we're doing here on the show
yes
[Laughter]
um we see um beadwork
which um janna contributed to which is
very exciting
um we see a native fashion
designed by native women so a lot of the
wardrobe which i consider like
art is all over regan which is exciting
there's also like really uh modern day
artifacts involved
one of the one of my favorite examples
of this is the
the clouds in the background of the
poster
were beated by janna so like it made its
way into the
the sort of like emotional graphic
language of our
show too in the coolest way oh hey ed
and jana
how did you prepare to be best friends
on screen
did what and and and was the writing was
being writers together part of the
process
yeah i mean i think hanging out in that
writer's room for months
just palin around with no stakes
like you know we hadn't cast janna at
that point so
there was there was no context to that
friendship other than we're just working
together and having fun and making each
other laugh
it certainly made the transition to
scene partner
a lot easier and just more organic
feeling
even though you have done so many films
and
uh tv shows in your career
like at your core you're a very good
improviser
and like we have very similar comedy
roots
and for me at least to be able to play
with ed
it was so helpful to have like a a
rapport
a real report but also like an on-screen
report which is
you know you have to like add uh
like invent jokes that friends share and
and that kind of stuff um it was really
easy it was really natural
all right everyone um we are around
needles down
[Laughter]
needles down beadwork up everybody show
your peacock
get the camera well i was about to put
this one down so
let me just hold that there oh beautiful
um everybody did an amazing job
especially great work
um from ty leclaire
i i couldn't have done it without you my
fingers are literally bleeding
i just want to say these beads are too
big i'm used to working with much
smaller beads
mine would be better if the beads were
smaller i'm just gonna say everyone
thank you so much for being
on this uh beating circle zoom call and
to you out there thanks so much for
watching don't forget to tune in
to rutherford falls now streaming on
peacock
[Music]
[Applause]